drones are becoming a vital tool for law
enforcement and other first responders
this week agencies from around the
country are in Colorado to train with
some of the latest drone technology only
on CBS this morning and I like when we
can say it I'm gonna say it again only
on CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca takes us inside the
massive Disaster Response drill this
train wreck and fire look like a
disaster but it's just a training drill
for drones more than two dozen local and
state agencies are training with drones
and new technology in a worst case
scenario and we got a behind-the-scenes
look there aren't too many places you
can crash and burn a real train but at
this federal facility 130 miles south of
Denver they're recreating crashes for
drone training move that camera to a
place that does something valuable as
more police and fire departments turn to
drones the first responders on the scene
arrived by air so the more we can use
this to do the work rather than send a
first responder in harm's way we're all
about that you're seeing heat the heat
Matt Sloan is CEO of sky fire his
company trains hundreds of emergency
personnel on how to use drones in
disasters how important is this drone in
assessing what's going on this is the
best tool that we've gotten since the
fire hose so instead of getting out
putting your life in danger walking
behind the house you can put the drone
up in the air in 30 seconds you can see
what's going on but firefighters were
trained to hold a hose not one of those
that's where you come in absolutely this
ball drone has a protected carbon fiber
sphere which gives it the ability to fly
into tight spaces and even bounce off
walls last month the New York City Fire
Department used one in a Manhattan
subway tunnel for a mass casualty
exercise
in April while no true Dom was on fire
the Paris Fire Department used their
drone to peer inside the Cathedral and
look for hotspots in a fire disaster a
regular drone camera cannot see through
flames or smoke but check this out
some first responders are using drones
with thermal cameras to find hotspots
and potential victims
you've got your attitude indicator
emergency crews from California to
Georgia it's travelled to this yearly
training exercise Jason Ritter is with
Georgia's Emergency Management Agency
his drones flew over this year's Super
Bowl in Atlanta you have SWAT team who
drills you have fire departments who
drill how important is it for you to
drill with drones keep that skill sharp
it's very important and because of that
week we practice and train monthly with
our aircraft drone technology continues
to evolve and Matt Sloan says each new
advancement could save both the lives of
first responders and citizens I think
next we're gonna start to see gas
detection sensors radiation detectors
we're really just scratching the surface
here what first responders learn here
they can take back to their communities
to not only use in accidents but in
maybe the aftermath of a hurricane or
other natural disasters
Omar Villafranca CBS News Pueblo
Colorado
Omar thank you god I like that you know
using technology and a really smart way
to help us and not it would keep us safe
basically keep people out of harm's yeah
I'm all for keeping us safe